Prime Minister let's kick off with the
biggest policy challenge you face which
is of course brexit you've put forward
some proposals for checks away from the
border but Simon Coveney has already
said overnight that this is a
non-starter are we heading towards a
noddle exit for me
there are various papers that have been
floating around her reporting I have
seen refers to a an idea for border post
as it were away from the border new what
we're not proposing that and I think
Simon would be would be right to to
reject that but let's see where we get
that's away from the border what I think
you need to do is clearly you've got the
whole of the UK has got to come out of
the EU customs union and if you're gonna
have Northern Ireland as part of a UK
customs you which is plainly essential
then somehow or other you have to solve
the problem of customs checks I won't
deny that this is the tough bit I just
say Teresa May agreed obviously you'll
know this very well in 2017 no hard
border she Brussels with Dublin or
related checks all controls preserving
and all Island economy this is a change
of policies yes that's right just to be
clear and yes and you you're absolutely
correct about that because because the
reality is well you you can't I can't
make both things work at once you have
to accept that there's got to be a
change he said it was a non-starter
well I'll it's you disagree obviously I
do but well it's I don't I'm not certain
that Simon is referring to what we're
proposing because we haven't yet
proposed it so just just quickly in
terms of moving towards a no deal at the
g7 when we spoke you told me there was a
reasonable chance of getting a deal do
you still feel that now as we go into
the yes I do I think we're more or less
where we were then at various I remember
our conversation then and things have
actually progressed and the UK has made
quite a big offer
Beth which I don't think that people
have perhaps unnecessarily appreciated
what we're saying is that we would
support alignment between Northern
Ireland and Ireland okay I'm not gonna
get I don't want to get into the details
very is let's wait to see the proposals
well it's one of the things that we have
already proposed there'll be more that
where we're going to say but I don't
think people with great respect I mean
it sounds complicated some aren't that
complicated
all we're saying is that for the
purposes of the Irish market but for the
purposes of free movement of cowards of
catalysis of Agra foods of all
agricultural and food products we can
treat the island of Ireland as a you
know we've got to wait until the
proposals come out well I would like to
move on to is can the public trust you
is the prime minister to obey the rule
of law I think the public can certainly
trust this government first of all to
obey the rule of law but also to get
done what we say that we're going to do
look at what I've done since I stood on
the steps of Downing Street said we're
going to hire another 20,000 police
officers the recruitment is underway I
said that we would have 20 new hospital
upgrades were doing that in fact in 10
years time as a result of the biggest
programme of hospital infrastructure for
our generation there are going to be 40
yes you Hoss but I want I said that we I
said that we would be rolling out
gigabit broadband and we're doing you
promise to deliver bricks on top of the
31st but obeying the law also includes
the Ben Act and that requires you to
request an extension from the EU by
October the 19th you know it well unless
parliament has approved a deal or no
deal so help me out how you going to do
what we're gonna do is we're going to
work very hard to get a deal we've been
we've been discussing that I want to get
a deal what I can tell you is that we
will obey the law
and we're going to come out on October
and the way to do that the best way to
do that is to get do you mean most
people in the country would like to see
us getting on with Brett so you know
some people don't support your approach
even your own brother Joe doesn't agree
with your brexit strategy and he walks
out of your government and he said he'd
stand down as an MP just six weeks after
agreeing to stick by you and this is
what he said in recent weeks I've been
torn between family law T and national
interests
it's an unresolvable tension at times
for others to take on my roles that was
been really hard for you yes yes but I'd
be look we're a very tight-knit pleasant
family and we we all love each other
very much but there's no doubt about it
we do disagree about about this issue
now I have to try to think what is in
the long-term interest of the country
and I have to try to think how we're
going to take this forward in a position
where you spend three and a half years
debating and disputing brexit is it
really in the national interest to keep
going beyond October is that really a
good idea
this wasn't a strategy you should pursue
I mean I saw you at the g7 your towel
was up and I saw you in Wakefield on the
day that Joe announced that he was
snowed and done you would like a
different Prime Minister you looked
really rattled well you know I can't
comment on on that but I love every day
that I'm privileged to do this every day
that privilege to do this job
obviously there are disagreements about
brexit there are disagreements within
families and they're different
disagreements across the country all
right I think this stuff is public as
well yes he made public I'm not I'm not
trying to pry into no you're not right
look where it's but what's the point I
make the point I know there's Rachel as
of course that's right but the the point
is that I don't think that we're going
to heal
this division in our country until we
get it done
and that maybe the maybe disagree with
that but I think that's the way though
and she said that my brother using was
like surrendering capitulation as if the
people stand in the way of the Blessed
will of the people as defined by the
seventeen point four million votes in
2016 should be hung drawn and quartered
tarred and feathered I think it's highly
reprehensible did you talk to her about
that after she said that to you well I'm
great I don't want to go into
conversations between members of my
family which is I say those lobbies and
tight-knit family but are you out on
still of course on the on the the
substantive issue about the so-called
surrender at the been act yes I think it
is reasonable to describe it in those
terms because what it does as you've
said just now is it not only obliges or
would oblige the UK to stay in there in
the EU but on the time set by the EU and
for a duration imagine to be the
citation to he decided about Jennifer
curry you've been accused of failing to
declare potential conflict of interest
in relation the awarding of public funds
to missus mister Curie and you're now
intentionally facing for an
investigation where you having an affair
with Jennifer i I've said what I've had
to say about that matter and I think
perhaps the most important point is that
I'm very very proud everything we did in
in London to promote the city abroad and
the question you asked I never comment
on that kind of thing because so you're
not the crucial crucial the crucial
thing is that in terms of promoting
London everything was done with complete
propriety and I may say I think it it is
very interesting it is interesting about
whether you miss use public money that's
why well I can certainly say there was
absolutely no there was no question of
that
and these are the accusations my former
colleague a former colleague Charlotte
Edwards that you squeezed her thigh
under a table 20 years ago it's
Charlotte lying well look I don't in any
way minimize the importance of these
types of allegation or these this this
type of thing but this is not true and
all I can say is that you know that I
can't anymore about what I want to do is
focus on the domestic agenda that we
have just in terms of Charlotte's on
whether you you say it wasn't true your
Health's actually Matt Hancock told
Channel 4 News
I know Charlotte well and I entirely
trust look what she has to say so he
believes her over you well I you have to
have I'm not certain that's the
conclusion that I would draw but I've
told you what I had to say about that
and what I want to do is focus on our
domestic agenda